welcome to this video playing Seminole
from Russia okay let's see what line the
what could I try out against them okay
it's playing the triangle I usually go
Quincy to hear hmm okay maybe see what
okay I fight this is always what I'm
hoping for to get this nice line against
the stone wall just quite quite a nice
position for wide get a very easy
development and it's not comparable to a
stone wall with with g3 actually some
the white pieces are just much more
actively placed RK is playing b6 hmm
okay I'm taking your play 95 some I can
also take can I take on d 695 ok either
I prefer that actually putting some
pressure on c6 so that you're not easily
can develop really no f3 was my idea and
opening up here just allows me to take
why why that's very strange I'll take on
c4 no text x don't see don't see the
point really know
yeah that's bishop d6 now this is the
big problem I go a three now Bishop c3
the spirit d 6 and I'm winning the house
really okay
what very strange stuff but ok I'm just
I'm just better here push your bay 3 the
c5 so I don't really know maybeee 594
years could be one of the good lines
yeah I had had the thread Bishop age six
but this is not a bad square for a night
as well ok so it's there a direct when
Bishop age six with the Queen g6 to come
maybe not but if i go here just
threatening bush of age six should be
quite good ok taking it now with this
winning actually it's because of night
f7 knock was Jack not Queen h 6j managed
to endear use less than a minute black
resign didn't help much yeah this was
okay it was very strange this camp I
didn't didn't really get what what was
happening I mean here okay white white
has the pretty typical EDM that simply
happens in this line but it was a bit
weird that he played after after f3
somehow it does not materialize on the
wall plate Queenie seven which was
really strange now I just take he and
and it's it's basically a basically a
win here there's 192 is even easier of
course yeah just this just traps the
bishop it's much much easier okay well I
was just seeing this and thought okay
well this is so good for white that I
didn't really look for anything better
but this is very straightforward
absolutely no defense Bishop h6e
couldn't couldn't prevent any more it's
just it's just too much with the offside
bishop and this night okay thanks for
watching